you know most people spend their life
with money telling them what to do and
we teach you to tell it what to do one
of the coolest things that happen is the
emotional switch that flips when you
have power over money instead of money
having power over you I remember it I
mean it feels like it's yesterday but I
was in my 20s and Sharon was telling the
story at dinner the other night our kids
over the vacation my youngest was asking
about like when we were first married he
was trying to get some of the timelines
straight on when different things happen
because he wasn't even born yet you know
and she was talking about at one of her
first jobs the lady taught her to cross
stitch she was working at a bank and
they sent and did nothing all day there
was a it was another bank that nobody
walked into you know it's an old
fashioned Savings & Loan and so she
learned to cross tension so she's 22
years old right gonna cross this we have
no money
we're broke I'm sitting at home doing
the checkbook 22 years old and I was
freaking out my heart is beating the
sweat is on my upper lip you get a
little sweat in the palm of your hands I
mean you know what fear feels like right
you know what stress feels like it has a
physical reaction in your body right
because this this stinkin checkbook I
finally worked it around and I got it we
had a dollar 40 left in the account
without bouncing a check and my new
bride of a few months walks in from her
new job with a bag in her hand she had
been to the cross-stitch store and had
spent $26 at the cross-stitch door that
we didn't have that was putting this
accounting to overdraft I just spent an
hour and a half balancing it I lost it
it was a huge fight over $26 because we
were going to bounce you know $400 worth
of checks because there's $26 probably
maybe the rent check was going to
balance I don't know but she just
wandered down there and just bought
cross-stitch without talking about we
had no plan we were like we were
stupid we were normal I was scared money
had power over me later I made a lot of
money later in that story and lost it
all
and I was scared and powered powerless
again money had power over me see this
whole thing of you are going to tell
your money what to do or you are going
to wonder where it went is a big deal
my friend Zig Ziglar says you're gonna
aim at something if you aim at nothing
you will hit it every time that's what
is it used to say if you aim at nothing
you will hit it every time and most
people aim at nothing with their lives
they're not intentional with raising
their children they're not intentional
I'm just going to be sweet to little
Johnny and little Johnny's a Hellion you
know you need to be intentional with
raising your children one of the
conversations were having what are the
implications of our tone you have to be
intentional with your marriage you have
to be intentional with your spiritual
walk you have to be intentional with
your physical taking care of your
physical body you don't accidentally win
people winning is never an accident it's
never an accident and so you've got to
put some tools in your belt to say I'm
going to make money behave I'm gonna
have power over money instead of money
having power over me that's what I'm
gonna do and that's what we discovered
25 years ago when I first started
teaching the material in Financial Peace
University that's it that's that's what
I found and you know what you can do
this stuff it is getting out of debt it
is working the baby steps it is building
your emergency fund it is taking the
steps to lay the foundation to become an
everyday millionaire not so that you're
some kind of rich not I'm not teaching
people to be rich not certain I'm not
teaching you that money makes you happy
but I want you to be an everyday
millionaire so you can be outrageously
generous so you can change your family
tree so your kid can go to college and
you don't have to think about it
so you can retire with dignity and don't
have to buy that cookbook 72 ways to
prepare Alpo and love it people retire
broke because they don't bother to plan
in the richest country the world has
ever known
Americans are filthy rich compared to
the rest of the world if you make thirty
eight thousand dollars a year you're in
the top 1% of income earners in the
world we're rich there's no excuse for
being broke except simple laziness lack
of intentionality lack of knowledge you
can fix this stuff